une hausse alarmante du kidnapping a eu
lieu en plein centre ville
plus de 200 personnes ont été kidnappées
à quelques mètres seulement de la dans
un hôtel réputé nous avons un rendez
vous un peu spécial un membre du gang a
accepté de venir témoigner face à notre
caméra
c'est exceptionnel car les mungiki sont
activement pour chasser par l'état
kenyan et il est interdit de les
rencontrer
pour cette interview nous avons demandé
l'aide d'une journaliste local dont nous
masquons le visage pour sa sécurité nous
la retrouvons dans le hall de l'hôtel
visiblement elle est inquiète
l'homme nous attend dans un restaurant
situé un peu plus loin lui aussi risque
gros à nous parler car ce qu'il a à nous
dire c'est exactement ce que la police
ne veut pas que l'on sache
il a 29 ans et il est mungiki depuis
huit ans d'emblée il tient à préciser
que les mungiki sont plus qu'un gang
c'est également une religion une
religion que l'on n'abandonne pas
facilement
si vous quittez la secte c'est
impardonnable
je connais quelqu'un qui a décidé de
partir et de devenir chrétien il osait
même prêcher dans le quartier le
lendemain de sa conversion l'année on
l'a attrapé et on lui a coupé la tête on
l'a ensuite déposé devant une station de
bus en ville
c'est une secte tentaculaire qui
contrôle les quartiers misérables des
grandes villes du kenya
sur ces images tournées par les mungiki
au même l'un des rites les plus secrets
de la secte le baptême ils sont plus
d'une centaine à se convertir et la
plupart portent les signes distinctifs
du gang les dreadlocks des rastas et les
couleurs de la secte rouge noire verte
et blanche
l'ambiance est plutôt conviviale et
détendue pourtant tous savent qu'ils
adhèrent à un gang à un groupe criminel
quelques prêtres dans une rivière
attendent les fidèles qu'ils vont
immergé dans l'eau froide
les nouveaux convertis sont tous très
jeune et il ya même des enfants
après la purification par l'eau il passe
entre deux bacs de cendres sacrée fête
de tabac 200 de chèvre d'uriné de tripes
pour finir il avale une sorte d' hostile
ensuite seulement ils deviennent des
mungiki pour la vie ou la mort ils
devront obéir aveuglément à leurs chefs
comme de couper la tête d'un policier ou
des petites nappes et des touristes
pour les kidnappings c'est très simple
on suit les gens dans la rue on repère
dans quel hôtel ils sont dans le centre
ville
qu'il soit blanc ou pas ça n'a pas
d'importance ce qui nous intéresse c'est
de savoir s'ils ont de l'argent une fois
le repérage effectué on demande du
renfort et on vient les prendre
l'année dernière deux enlèvements ont
fait la une des journaux locaux une
belge et une allemande ont été
séquestrés nu pendant une semaine
évidemment ça ne choque pas notre homme
les femmes sont violées si les
kidnappeurs le décide ils font ce qu'ils
veulent mais encore une fois la seule
chose qui nous intéresse c'est l'argent
et ce n'est pas prêt de s'arrêter tant
qu'il y aura des pauvres sans emploi
mort de faim les mungiki trouveront sans
problème de nouveaux disciples sindian